[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hi.
And welcome to episode number
183 of the weekly "Google Cloud
Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mirchandani,
and I'm here
with my colleague Gabi Ferrara.
Hey, Gabi.
GABI FERRARA: Hello, Mark.
How are you?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I'm doing well.
How are you doing?
GABI FERRARA: Good.
A bit away, but I'm good.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I
feel like we haven't
chatted since the last
time we did a podcast.
And it feels like it's
been at least a month.
GABI FERRARA: No,
it was in Next.
So I think it was, like, two
months ago, three months ago,
almost.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And
that feels like years ago.
So it has been quite a while.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
Well, today, we're going to
be talking about Google Cloud
Platform UX.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very exciting.
Looking forward to that.
But before we get
into that content,
we do want to tease our little
question of the week here.
And I think this is one you know
a lot about, because I'm really
not certain of it,
which is, you know
there's been a lot of cool stuff
about Cloud Build and Cloud
Run.
But what is the simplest
way for me in Google
to work with these containers
and then actually push them up
to the cloud?
GABI FERRARA: Well, I'll
tell you all about it
later, how you can make your
job easier with the containers
to deploy on your Kubernetes
in Cloud Run installation.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I'm
looking forward to that.
But I do know that before we
even get to our main content,
we also want to talk about
our cool things of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GABI FERRARA: OK.
You can start.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK.
Perfect.
Don't worry.
I've got plenty lined up here.
The favorite cool thing
I've had for this week
is a recent blog post that
was talking a little bit more
about committed use discounts.
So if you're not familiar
with what they are,
they're basically a way of
setting up a reservation
and saying, I'm going to use
a certain amount of cores
or memory or local
SSD or even GPUs
over the next one
year or three years.
And when you do that, you end
up getting those resources
for a little bit cheaper.
So if you've got these
large static workloads,
then it might make a
lot of sense to say, OK.
Well, I know I'm going to
be running a medium CPU,
maybe two CPUs
over the next year.
So why don't I go ahead and
pay a little bit less for them?
And then there's
also now a report
that you can actually look
at an interactive dashboard
that kind of shows you where
your commits are being used.
And you can look at it
per project, per region
and say, OK.
Well, this is a good
candidate for me
to set up a committed
use discount here,
because I've got all these
cores that I'm statically using.
So I find that report
really exciting.
And I think a lot of
people can use that.
Along with just the general
ability to save money,
I think people are
going to like it.
GABI FERRARA: Go
save your money.
Nobody complains
about that, actually.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
It's kind of a universal.
Everybody likes to save money.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
So what I have to
talk about, it's
part of what we were talking
before in the podcast,
on the network part.
So it's a blog post that came
out on the main blog post
that we have on Google
Cloud, talking about how
Google as the named leader from
the data security portfolio
vendors from 2019 report
increases your network
security in the cloud by
using three main ways.
Of course, there are
other ways to do so.
But those are the
three main ways
they go in depth on
the blog post, which
are securing your
internet-facing services,
secure VPC for
private deployment,
and micro-segment access to
your application and services.
I think the latter one
is like what we "IIM."
So take a look and see how
you can make more secure
your deployments on the cloud.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I think this is another post
in that same line of blog posts
that you just mentioned, the
networking in-depth series
that just kind of deep
dives on some of these
cloud networking principles.
Especially for
people who may not
be as familiar with
the cloud, they
can be tremendously helpful.
GABI FERRARA: I don't
know anything about that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, then perfect.
This was a great place to start.
One other thing that I
recently didn't know anything
about and now still only know
just scratching the surface,
we also have a
cool little article
about building chat
bots using Dialogflow.
So Dialogflow, if I
describe this correctly,
it's really like the way
to build a chat interaction
system.
So you can understand
what people are saying
and then kind of
create responses.
And you can use some of the
machine learning aspects.
There's actually another
really, really cool playlist
called "Deconstructing
Chatbots" that I highly
recommend on the Google Cloud
Platform YouTube channel that
goes into a little bit more
detail about Dialogflow
and some of the other
tools around it.
But we've also got
a team-based chat
tool called "Hangouts Chat,"
which is what a lot of us
use here internally.
And then people who
use G Suite have
that so they can
kind of communicate
between their teams, share
messages and information.
Well, you can actually build
a chatbot with Dialogflow
and easily integrate
it into Hangouts Chat.
So now, if you've got repetitive
work systems or things
that you need to do
on a regular basis--
I think the most common
one that we probably
use here is searching for
hilarious animated GIFs
and then inserting them into
chat, a very common use case.
But I built one
or two test ones.
It's very cool to
think about, how can I
automate certain
things, whether that's
going to be setting up a
meeting or even aggregating
votes on things?
I think there are some
cool possibilities there.
So it's super,
super cool to see.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah, like alerts.
Oh, the system's going down.
[ALARM BLARES]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
notifications and alerts.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah, so you
don't actually wake up people
at 3:00 AM in the morning.
[BUZZING]
If people are already
awake on the chat,
you don't need to
worry about that.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
OK.
And the other cool thing
of the week that we have,
it's in regards to App Engine.
We updated the runtimes
for several languages.
And one of them is Java.
This is running now the latest
long-term support version,
which it is is 11, although it's
better yet, and also updated
the versions for GO for 112.
And PHP, now the latest
one, which it is 7.3,
which will give you
more performance--
and don't forget.
You can use all of those new
runtimes on your free tier
on App Engine.
So just click on the
link and give it a look.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So lots
of new options for people
who are using App
Engine or people who
haven't started using it yet--
I feel like every
couple of weeks,
we see more and more runtimes
and more and more support
added.
So hopefully,
that'll kind of catch
a wider audience of people who
are able to use App Engine.
GABI FERRARA:
Yeah, because there
are languages that have
LTS versions every month,
so hard to keep it up.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Exactly.
So the more support, the better.
I think another
thing that people
like besides saving
money is support
for their favorite
languages and staying
on top of those versions.
GABI FERRARA:
Yeah, because also,
there is the part of security.
If you're running
an older version,
probably there are known bugs.
And that's not cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
Well, those are some very,
very cool things of the week.
But I think we should get
right into our main content
with Michael, a
product designer.
I think this will
be a really fun one.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
I'm really interested
to know how we do things
on UX in Google Cloud.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GABI FERRARA: So we are here
today with Michael Kleinerman.
He's a product designer on
Google Cloud Platform for UX.
Michael, tell us more about you.
What do you do?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: Hi.
Thank you for having me.
Like you said, I'm a product
designer on the Google Cloud
Platform team.
Before joining Cloud, I
worked on the Android and also
the YouTube team
in the Bay Area.
And I moved to New
York two years ago.
So that's the time that I
started working on Cloud,
first leading the UX for Cloud
Firestore, which was touching
a little bit on Google Cloud
console but also the Firebase
console.
And after that
product launched, I
moved to the Centralized
Design System team
for Cloud, a team that
supports all the system
components for the UI
on the Cloud console.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And if
I understand correctly,
you've also actually
been doing this
for a couple of different years
from before you joined Google,
right?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: Yes.
I had the opportunity
to touch design systems
since 2010 or 2011.
And prior to Google, when I
was working on Microsoft Xbox,
it was the initial work that
was happening with Kinect,
if you remember.
And so we had to
do the whole design
system for this new input,
which was body gestures.
And everything had to
work quite differently.
It was same for
Android, because I
was part of the team that
worked on Android TV.
It was the first
time that we were
kind of forking the OS to
work on different platforms
and different
device form factors.
So we had to also rethink,
what is the new design system?
How do all the components and
UI widgets now work for the TV?
It became very familiar
when I started working
on that in the Cloud platform.
GABI FERRARA: How does one
become a product designer?
What did you do in college?
What attracted
you to this field?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: Yeah.
So that's a good question,
because I did so many things
before landing in UX.
I think my background is in 3D
motion graphics and new media--
so everything that
was happening back
in the day with Flash
interactive websites.
I was doing CD-ROMs with
Macromedia Director,
all the ancient stuff.
And I worked in an agency
where our job was just
like an agency.
We took care of all
the client's needs,
including branding, logo design,
motion graphics, web designs,
all sorts of things.
It was really good for me to
just get a breadth of work
in graphic design and
just design in general.
And that's at that
time, it was starting
to become a more defined role,
like interaction designer.
And so I moved at
that point to Seattle
and started working
for Microsoft.
And there were actual
interaction designers there.
And so I thought, well, this
is falling from heaven, almost.
Everything that I've
liked in the design
world so far sort
of all families
up into this amazing role
of becoming an interaction
designer, thinking
about everything
end to end, from
visuals to audio
to flows and mental models
and psychology and research.
And I just fell in love with it.
And so I ended up following
that path to what I do today.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So this
is a question mostly borne
of my own ignorance.
But how come nobody
appreciates interaction design?
And is that correct, because
I kind of get the feeling
that a lot of people don't think
about it first and foremost
and, in fact, don't think
about it at all sometimes.
GABI FERRARA: But isn't that
a result of good design,
if you don't think
about it as a user?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: Yeah.
I think that's right.
If the interface is invisible
and the interaction designer
has worked on that so hard
to just really get out
of the way, then yeah, you
should strive for that.
But yeah, I guess that's the
other angle of that question.
For example-- I don't know.
If you have a startup,
you're thinking,
oh, we need designers
because it's the trend.
We just see it everywhere.
And you just happen to
hire visual designers,
because you think that's
all it's encompassing.
I've seen a lot of
scenarios like that.
Yeah, you end up
having some gaps.
I've known a lot
of visual designers
that end up understanding
so much of everything.
And they know how to
prototype, and their skills
are just amazing.
But some are just kind of
coming out of a background that
is just very focused on that.
And so you can't really expect
to have a visual designer
think about all the other
aspects of all the other design
disciplines.
So I agree with you.
Sometimes, it's easy to think
that the disciplines are all
the same.
But no, this is why you
have a specialized motion
designer, a sound designer,
an interaction designer,
a visual designer, and so forth.
GABI FERRARA: So how does
designing systems at Google
work for you?
How is this process?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: So I
guess there are two audiences.
For me, who I'm trying to
build a design system on top
of material design, I'm
having to sort of build
a context between
what Google uses
and then what products that
are built on top of Google
are using.
And there's a
designer that actually
consumes what we currently
have under Google Material.
And they just go to a
website like material.io,
which is where you just
find guidelines for all
the patterns or the components.
But in my case, when I
joined Cloud Firestore,
what I had to do was
adopt material design
for the first time.
Nobody in cloud had
any parts of the UI
in the material design language.
It was still I think called
"Kennedy" before they
launched the material design.
So it was really tough, because
it was the very first product
that was trying to do that.
And it was still catching
up, because at that point,
they were launching already the
second generation of material
design.
And we were just trying to
start with the first one.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And to
take a step back here,
could you define
"material design"?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: Yeah.
Sure.
So material design is kind of
the first design system that
was driven by Google to
understand how the components
and patterns work across
different types of devices
for different screen sizes.
So there were other
design systems out there,
like Bootstrap,
things like that,
where you have a
library of widgets
or a library of components where
a designer or developer can
just start using as boilerplate
to create any website.
But nobody had
really thought, OK.
Now, we're looking
at watches and phones
and TVs and everything.
And how would a design
system that spans
across multi-device
platforms would work?
And I think that's
how it started.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Gotcha.
So you were talking
about how you
were working with the
Cloud team in helping
them implement design.
But they hadn't really
caught up to material design.
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN:
That's right,
specifically talking of
the Google Cloud console.
Firestore-- I don't
know if you guys
are familiar with Firestore.
But it lives in both
consoles, Firebase and Cloud.
So there are completely
different design languages.
Firebase, I think they
were a little bit ahead.
They were already
adopting material design.
The roundness of the
buttons, they already
looked like material design.
And the negative
space, the white space
that you would see
on every single page,
was already speaking
that design language.
And on Google Cloud, we
just hadn't gotten there.
And so that was kind
of the first thing
that I did as I was building
the UX for Firestore.
I was also trying
to figure out, how
do we just start implementing
all these new components that
are coming from material design?
GABI FERRARA: So all
of these creative ways
you do to make UX
design for the user,
how do you reach all
those conclusions?
Is that a design process?
Is there research?
What do you do?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: So you mean
for implementing the design
system?
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
You do a decision, like, let's
say, oh, this menu should not
be this size
because x, y, and z.
And research shows that
this would be worse.
I don't know.
Decisions need to be made.
And what do you base
those decisions on?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: Yeah.
So I think at the sort of
foundational level, which
is what we get from
material design team,
they had to go
through a lot of that.
They had to go through a
lot of testing and research
to figure out what is the right
size for a button or the tap
target for making it work
on all different devices--
contrast for accessibility.
I guess those are all
the requirements that
have to go for
that design system
to sort of be published for
everyone to start using it.
The same goes for Cloud.
So what's been happening is that
the initial design system that
was composed under
material design
was almost focused
on consumer products.
And Cloud starts reaching
this new space, which
is called "Enterprise,"
where you are thinking
about components that are
a little bit more complex,
like tables that need
to account for millions
and millions of columns, with
raw data coming in super fast
and things like that.
And that was not part of
the library of components.
So we do the same
sort of process.
We test the functionality
of every single element
in that table, the
accessibility of it,
until it reaches all
the requirements.
And then we can say, this is
ready for people to use it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You kind of
mentioned a little bit just
earlier about accessibility.
Google has some
pretty tremendous
accessibility guidelines
built into everything we do.
How does that kind
of play together
with not just the visual design,
but the instructional design,
all the design?
Everything you're
building, you also
need to keep
accessibility in mind.
How do those kind of
interplay together?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: Yeah.
So it's a super top
priority for Cloud.
And Google has different
sort of requirement levels
that you also might
need to decide
as a team which one
are we shooting for,
at least this year
or this quarter.
And basically, I think they
fall into primary use cases.
In your product,
you always know what
are the top three
sort of flows or tasks
that a user comes to your
product to solve or to do.
And focusing on those main ones
could get you to, I don't know,
the first or the second level
of accessibility requirements.
Now, if you keep fixing
accessibility issues
for the secondary
use cases, then you
can get to the next level.
And we're actually
now thinking, what
happens beyond that last
level, which is really
going through a screen reader,
for example, experience,
where you can actually
accomplish everything you do.
But it's not a nice
experience, not as delightful
as, I don't know, what you would
see on YouTube when you upload
a video or something like
that-- so really focusing on,
how do you really make the
experience better for people
with any disability?
And I guess the other aspect
is from the design system
point of view, how do you
make sure that there's
a lot of guidance also for
people that are consuming
the components and the
patterns that you have
in the design system website?
So not only at the component
level, but at the page level--
we already know people come
to the cloud design system
to create some sort of page
that lists all the resources,
resources being all
your virtual machines
or all your buckets from
storage or databases or data
sets from machine
learning models.
It doesn't matter what it is.
We kind of know that
that's a pattern,
and we provide guidance
for accessibility,
how to traverse
through the whole page.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
that's really interesting,
because you were just mentioning
that even inside of Cloud,
Firebase had already
kind of adopted
a lot of these guidelines
and was at a different place,
even though Firebase
is under Cloud.
And you were also
mentioning earlier
that you worked on the YouTube
team and the Android team.
So these are all
different guidelines,
and they're at different
places in terms
of the material design.
What do they do the
same, and what are they
doing differently?
And why aren't they all
kind of at the same place?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: Yeah.
So with Firebase, it's
a very unique case.
And I think it does have
a similarity to YouTube,
in the sense that it's
all part of Google.
But they have their own brand.
So they're not really
consuming material design
or Google material
design exactly
as a Google product, a product
that is branded by Google.
So YouTube and Firebase
are these two snowflakes.
And what they've
done is basically,
they break a little bit of
the style of the entire design
system to fit their brand.
And it works.
In the case of
Firebase, their audience
has always been almost
entry-level developers or even
startups.
What they want is just to
make it super easy to just
get started with
an app, an idea,
even if it's a
prototype or something.
And they give you all the
stuff that you need in there
to get started very quick.
If you scale, then you
can almost graduate,
cross that big bridge, to
the Google Cloud Platform
to then start using all the
other bells and whistles,
analytics and machine
learning and all that stuff.
The difference that I've
seen, for example, on Cloud
and all the other
products, specifically
Android and YouTube, were
you draw this difference
between the consumer world
and then the enterprise world.
And I think we all
empathize with consumers.
It's all the apps that
we use, Google Maps
and everything we use today.
And so it's kind
of, I think, easier
to, as a cross-functional
team, design something
that is easy to use.
When you have PMs and engineers
and designers and researchers,
the entire team is
all really focusing
on making it super easy.
With the enterprise world,
it's a little harder,
because not everyone's going
to be using a machine learning
model in Google Cloud.
I don't know how to do that.
So it starts getting
kind of tough.
So there's a lot of
preconceptions, I feel like.
How much information do
you need in the screen?
Or is this OK for
a data scientist?
There are things
that we don't know.
It's still very, very early
for us to start figuring out
how the consumer and
enterprise products should
merge and should start
thinking, the data scientist
is no different than my
mom that is using YouTube.
We're just humans.
How do we make it simple
and consistent for anyone?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: In my
knowledge of enterprises,
most of them have
people in them.
[CHIME]
And people tend to be the same.
Maybe that's a bad assumption.
I would have thought that the
design principles would apply
equally, but I guess it
sounds like, as you're saying,
there are a lot of
different factors
to take into consideration
when designing these systems
for almost different personas.
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN:
That's right.
GABI FERRARA: Is
there any resource
you would like to share
about the job you do,
if people want to get much
in-depth in the subject?
You mentioned material design.
I think it's one of the sources.
But what people
should be looking for
to make their product more
accessible and more efficient?
Here, we have the guidelines,
as you mentioned, for Cloud,
for YouTube, for Firebase.
But in your opinion, where
can they get more in depth
and adopt best practices--
would-be best practices,
I think-- for product design?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: I
think the material.io
website is a really good place
to sort of stay up to date.
They're updating that
website frequently and just
adding all the new hotness that
my designers or even teams that
don't have designers
should be learning from.
So I think that's a
really good resource.
I know other accessibility
sort of centralized websites
within Google, but not entirely
sure outside of Google.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I think it's interesting,
because there's no universal,
this works for everybody design.
There's no universal,
this kind of works
for everybody accessibility.
You said you worked at
a couple of companies,
including Microsoft, and
then maybe a smaller agency
before working at Google.
What does that look like
when you go from one place
to another?
And how does that kind
of influence your thought
about the design systems
that you're building?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: Yeah.
It's crazy how moving
to big corporations,
you feel the difference.
Also, at that point,
you're not just
designing something and trying
to make it fit your needs.
But you have to
start with trying
to understand how to consume the
already-in-place design system.
So that's one of the
goals of design systems.
You're supposed to
build new things that
are coherent with the rest
of the design language
or family of components.
That's definitely
a big difference
that you would feel from
a startup or a place
where you're still not there, in
terms of a clear plan to reuse
components as much as possible.
But you're just the
early phases of building.
And I think building reusable
components comes much after.
So it does feel quite different
when you join a big company,
and then all those
reusable components
are already in place.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: What you
were talking about with kind
of going to a new company
and joining all their assets,
what we've seen--
and this hearkens back to
you working at Microsoft,
you talking about the Kinect,
because it was very interesting
when the Kinect was out.
For people who don't
know, the Kinect was--
I'm not sure if it's
actually still around
or if they're still working
on it as a separate tool.
But it was a peripheral that
you could attach to your Xbox.
And it would read you
with multiple cameras.
And you could basically
interact with your Xbox
through hand motions and
gestures and a microphone,
as well.
So it was a brand new paradigm
for interacting with your TV
at that time, because most
people were playing games
with controllers.
And we saw a really interesting
kind of almost two interfaces
mixing together when you had
your controller-level interface
and then you had the
Kinect interface.
And I think after the Kinect
was out for a little while,
they kind of almost
merged those together.
Or they tried to create an
interface that worked for both.
And I had a Kinect,
and I had an Xbox.
And I play a decent
amount of Xbox.
I thought it was
really interesting,
because some of the design
decisions in my opinion
were actually worse on
the controller side,
because they tried to
fold in the Kinect one.
So that's a very
concrete example.
But I guess in terms of
the long story there,
the question is, how do you
make those kinds of decisions,
especially when you're talking
about adding a new redesign?
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: Yeah.
That's an interesting
story where we were just
dealing with an unknown.
No one had ever done
hand body gesture UIs.
And there was nowhere
else to go and find
references or inspiration
or research that
was applicable to what
we were trying to do.
So I think what
was happening also
was hypotheses that it was the
best way for you to start using
the UI, pick the game
or pick the movie
or whatever you
were trying to do.
And that way, you wouldn't
have to pick up the controller.
And I think even the tagline
was "you are the controller"
or something of that.
And it turned out
that yeah, it was not
nice to use your hands
to get to the content you
were looking for.
So it was better to use the
smarts of Kinect to play games
because it was challenging.
If you were playing, I
don't know, a tennis game,
you're using your hands.
And you were missing or losing.
It was fun.
It didn't matter,
because you were just
excited to just
continue playing.
But that same
mental model doesn't
apply for you trying to find
a movie or a game in the UI.
It's frustrating.
So I think that's
when they deviated.
I really don't know what the
answer is today, because I
haven't played in a long time.
But they deviated in when do you
use each controller for what.
Or each input is good
for certain things.
And how do we make sure that we
teach people when to use each?
And what are the strengths of
each of the inputs that we're
offering people?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I would
love to see a follow-up
conversation.
I'm assuming you still
have some contacts.
But can we just get someone from
Microsoft, someone from Sony,
someone from Nintendo?
Can we all just
sit down in a room
and hyper-analyze their
video game platforms
and talk about the design?
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
All right.
B2, we're going to
leave that one to you.
Awesome.
Well, thanks so much
for joining us, Michael,
and teaching us a lot about
kind of the thought process that
goes into design.
MICHAEL KLEINERMAN: My pleasure.
Thank you.
GABI FERRARA:
Thank you, Michael.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very cool
talk with Michael-- super, super
glad that he had a chance
to sit down with us
and tell us a little bit more.
I wouldn't have really known.
Product designer-- it's
such an important part
of what literally
everyone uses when
they have to use the platform.
So I think it's
really fascinating
to see, look, there's
a lot of thought that
goes into these decisions.
GABI FERRARA: And responsibility
and implications, too,
of decisions that people do.
So that was very enlightening.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So in
another form of enlightenment,
I'd love to ask the
question of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So my question was
really about how
to work with containers locally
and then kind of put them
into the cloud.
So we know that you can build
a container using Docker.
And then you have to submit it.
And then you have to pull it up.
And then you use a build system.
And then you have to
put it in the cloud.
That seems pretty complicated.
Could you kind of walk us
through what of those steps
are necessary and
what makes sense?
GABI FERRARA: So when I first
started with Kubernetes,
for instance, I did not
know much about Docker.
And in fact, it used to be a
thing that I loved to hate,
because I didn't
understand how it worked.
And now, I do.
I think I understand
a bit how it works.
And a lot of the menial
tasks I discovered
can be really simple if
you're using the cloud.
For instance, if you're running
a code locally and let's say
you are in a place, you
don't have good internet,
and you cannot do those Docker
pulls to download all those
images, neither to push your
image to the cloud so you can
deploy into Cloud Run or
Kubernetes, for instance,
or even Compute Engine,
so what you can do--
and it saves a lot of time.
From your terminal, you can use
the Build command from G Cloud.
And it says to submit the code
that's on the root folder.
And once you do that, it's
going to do for you that Docker
build, the Docker tag, the
Docker push, and in the end
send it to Container Registry.
It's going to be available
for all your projects on GCP--
so a win-win situation.
You don't use your internet.
You just use Google's
internet to do it for you.
And everything else is just fun.
Then you just can deploy into
Kubernetes or Compute Engine
or even on Cloud Run just
with simple command lines.
So I think using
Cloud Build, it's
going to save a lot
of development time
on your day-to-day task.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
It sounds like a one-line
command that replaces probably
five or six different
processes, all of which
had their own
little nuances when
you had to run them--
so super happy to see
that it's a lot simpler than
hopefully it used to be.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
And you don't need to have that
much knowledge of Cloud Build.
You don't need to
create fancy things.
If you just want the basics--
and usually, when you're
creating proof of concepts,
that's just enough.
And that helps a lot.
If you want more, you can dig
into a bit on the documentation
that's on the blog post.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I think we've seen some pretty
cool customization to it,
that you can set up really
complex build pipelines.
But it sounds like even without
setting anything up, just
the ability to speed
up container building
and deploying is awesome.
GABI FERRARA: I
agree, because nobody
wants to stay there pushing an
image to the internet over 3G
or airplane internet.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There are some
universal truths this episode,
right?
Everyone likes money.
Nobody likes to spend time
wasting it doing nothing.
I think everyone can
relate to this episode.
It'll be very relatable.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
GABI FERRARA: Yeah, I think so.
It's a nice one.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So I know
we're almost out of time here.
So where are we going to be?
Gabi, you have any
traveling coming up?
GABI FERRARA: Not
for a few months.
I'm going to be staying here in
New York, just doing my stuff.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I've been
looking at a couple calendars,
and I think that is going
to be the reoccurring
theme of our entire team here.
Yeah.
I'll pretty much be
staying in the Bay Area.
I'll be filming with
some more customers.
But in this case, it'll be
down in South Bay, which
is, thankfully, pretty
close to San Francisco.
So I'd still call
that pretty local.
And then Brian, Aja,
Michelle, John, Mark--
everyone seems to be staying
pretty close to their home
offices.
GABI FERRARA: I don't know.
Mark just announced
some conference.
I don't know when.
It's a travel, though.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I have no idea.
So we'll be relatively quiet.
And then hopefully, the
next time Mark Mandel is on,
he can tell us a little bit
more about where he was going.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
Curious to know more about it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Awesome.
All right.
Well, thanks everyone
for listening.
And we'll talk to
y'all next week.
GABI FERRARA: Talk
to you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]